Well, let's take another quick quiz and this one like the broken prime number function I showed you
is designed to pry into the limitations of coverage metrics.
So your job now is to insert a bug into the stats module, that is to say make it wrong but in a
way that's undetectable by test cases that get full statement coverage.
So test 1 is a function that you write which contains either the
test cases you just submitted or different ones.
These test cases together need to achieve 100% statement coverage for the stats function
but we must not reveal the bug--that is to say you're broken stats function needs to return
the correct answer for the test cases presented here.
The second thing I want you to do is define a function test 2, which also
calls the stats function, and this one should reveal the bug.
Your assignment is to break the stats function in such a way that the flaw is undetectable
by test cases that you design would get a 100% test coverage, but also you
need to show us what the flaw is by supplying a second test case.